re bonsoir gerald bon soit patrice six
jours du vote
faisons le tableau de la fiscalité ce
que nous proposent les principaux partis
on commence par les conservateurs oui
exactement allons voir un peu ce que les
conservateurs présentent mais je vous
dirais qu'une bonne partie de la
plateforme des conservateurs a déjà été
présenté la mise à jour du mois de
novembre dernier et le budget du mois
d'avril dernier avait déjà beaucoup de
mesures budget ou alors le seul il
compte d'épargné libre d'impôt de
doubler le plafond ça c'était dans
budget la prestation universelle pour
garde d'enfants c'était dans la mise à
jour je vous donne un exemple c'est un
gain de 325 $ pour une famille avec deux
enfants qui fait 100 1000 par année ça
c'est la prestation universelle pour la
garde d'enfants
après impôts bien sûr le fractionnement
du revenu pour les couples avec enfants
ça aussi ça a été annoncé et la
réduction des cotisations d'assurance
emploi au cours des prochaines années
parce que il ya des surplus à
l'assurance-emploi principales mesures
déjà annoncées cela dit depuis le début
de la campagne électorale les
conservateurs ont fait d'autres
promesses
un crédit d'impôt de 15 pour cent pour
la rénovation domiciliaire donc ce une
façon de stimuler la construction
stimuler l'économie
on part d'une économie d'impôt moyenne
qui peut aller jusqu'à 600 dollars dans
les autres mesures un crédit d'impôt
pour les aînés célibataires ou les aînés
veuf de 2000 $ économie d'impôt moyenne
297 $ par année dans ce cas ci autre
mesure qui va intéresser les jeunes
familles les jeunes ménages qui veulent
s'acheter une maison
les conservateurs proposent d'augmenter
le régime d'accès à la propriété
vous savez vous avez droit d'acheter une
première propriété de retirer 25 mille
dollars de vauré air pour faire une mise
de fonds sans payer d'impôts on passe
donc à 35000 dollars
ça c'est une mesure qui est proposé par
les conservateurs également augmenté la
subvention pour le régime enregistré
d'épargne-études principalement pour les
familles à revenu faible et les revenus
moyens et on rappelle la baisse d'impôts
qui est prévu pour les pme les petites
et moyennes entreprises
11 % le taux d'imposition actuellement
le pas 3 9% ce qui amènerait 1000 $ de
plus par pme en économie
alors voilà bien résumé l'offre des
conservateurs
voyons l'offre des libéraux qu'après on
vous donnerez votre grain scène mais
voyons celle délibère allocation
canadienne pour enfants qui va venir
remplacer chez les libéraux toutes les
prestations qui existe déjà
familial on pense à la prestation
universelle pour enfants on veut tout
enlever ça pour amener une seule
allocation les libéraux calcul que ça
signifierait pour une famille avec deux
enfants indiens qui pourraient aller
2050 à 3950 dollars par famille donc ça
c'est la location canadienne pour
enfants qui est le coeur je vous dirais
de la plateforme libérale
on propose également une baisse d'impôts
et une hausse d'impôts baisses d'impôts
sur les revenus d'à peu près 45 milles à
90 milles dollars donc on dit qu'on
touche principalement la classe moyenne
le taux d'imposition de 22% passerait
donc à 22 5% et ça signifierait donc une
économie maximale annuelle de 670
dollars taux d'impôt de 30 3% sur les
revenus dépassant 200 mille dollars donc
pour taxer les plus riches pour bien
comprendre que le taux de 33 %
s'applique après 200 milles et pas avant
2 100 mhz et ce à partir de 200 milles
que les personnes qui sont à ce niveau
de revenus pourraient donc payer 33 %
d'imposition on propose la fin du
fractionnement du revenu pour les coûts
puisque les conservateurs ont amené
seraient annulés par les libéraux et on
propose également d'annuler la
bonification du celi qui était rendu à
10000 donc on baisserait le plafond dans
ce cas-ci pour les années aux du
supplément de revenu garanti de 10 % et
principalement pour les aînés à faible
revenu vivant seules
donc ce signifie c'est ça pourrait
signifier un gain de 1000 $ par année et
baisse du taux d'imposition également
pour les pme pour les libéraux également
voilà les libéraux et le npd
il ya bien sûr les garderies bea montre
show web et les garderies pour le npd
c'est ça ça c'est le coeur soit aussi
pour les familles 15 dollars par jour
pas d'impact au québec parce qu'il ya
déjà des garderies à faible coût au
québec mais à calgary et économie
mensuelle de 750 pour une famille à
toronto 1400 dollars d'économies comme
ça à l'extérieur et l'intérieur du
québec retour du crédit d'impôt pour les
fonds de travailleurs à 15%
vous savez que les le gouvernement
conservateur a annulé les crédits
d'impôts c'est est sur le point
d'arriver à zéro pour cent ceux qui
disent un point leur amènerait à 15%
donc économie d'impôt 225 dollars en
2016 375 dollars les années suivantes
le npd propose également une
augmentation du supplément de revenu
garanti un revenu supplémentaire qui ré
de 250 à 2000 $ par année pour les deux
cent mille années les plus pauvres on
propose aussi la fin du fractionnement
de revenu et la fin également de la
bonification du celi dont vous allez
voir sur notre prochain tableau le
fractionnement du revenu pour les coupes
pour les aînés mais pour les coupes se
sera annulée avec enfants la baisse du
plafond du chili le 10 mai la 5000 $
hausse du taux d'impôt des grandes
entreprises actuellement de 15 il
passera 10 7% avec un impact donc de 130
mille dollars par grandes entreprises et
la baisse de taux d'impôts pour les pme
seraient également dans la plateforme du
npd alors gérad la question mais quelle
est la plateforme la plus généreuse
prenons pour la classe moyenne
je pense que toutes les plateformes
visent la classe moyenne donc si vous
êtes une famille avec enfants
vous avez quoi vous servir dans chacune
des plateformes à différents ils vu ça
des moins et plus et des moins garderie
d'un côté baisses d'impôts de l'autre
côté fractionnement de revenu du côté
des conservateurs donc un peu tout le
monde visent la classe moyenne avec
enfants lorsque vous n'êtes pas dans la
classe moyenne avec enfants les
propositions des partis sont beaux
plus chiche sont beaucoup moins ciblée
et c'est beaucoup plus du point de vue
philosophique qu'on va se prononcer en
faveur du plate forme d'une plate forme
ou d'une autre à ce moment c'est un le
point sur la fiscalité fédérale
merci beaucoup merci patrice forme à
avoir